để giữa hình xấu sạp nhất là bây giờ thì nhà ăn cũng hay đi lưu đi tởi giữa hình xa ngọt
nhưng mỗi đứt vào bản đưa ăn đi ra xa ngọt đặc mua đồ hình xa
thì nhà ăn hay đi ăn trụn được nếu như trong lòng năng tay
và bây giờ bây giờ bây giờ bây giờ bây giờ mọt của nhà ăn trong lòng năng tay
bây giờ ăn hay ngoại mẹ ăn là pasong ăn đi về thì nhà ăn hay mẹ để giữa ăn mẹ để ra chất không
để tạo mất trí sau này
để đầm còn tình nhớ mình quay về lại
bôi nhà cậm mình quay lại về lại về bạn
quay lại về ăn trí em
đi ra nó chắc là cái đặc biệt vào thì sau này khi mà ăn được đi hương hậm nực mua
đi qua nhà đi qua trang ha đà đi cậm đi, nó ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm, ngọt gầm để ăn trí em